these are the images of Monica valtodano
when she was a Sandinista rebel
commander in the late 1970s alongside
president Daniel Ortega when both were
fighting to overthrow Nicaragua's then
dictatorship
today she's not only an exile fleeing
from Ortega but is one of 317 government
opponents stripped of their nationality
essentially made stateless
at first I was dumbfounded then angry
Furious but I admit it's a hard blow
Monica and her husband Julio Lopez were
also stripped of their citizenship I
understand you've lost more than just
your citizenship
although we don't accept Ortega's
actions they're having consequences
they've erased our birth certificates
from the Civil registry as though we'd
never been born they've confiscated our
property and canceled our pensions it's
not enough to make us stateless they
want to make us destitute
among the latest 94 Nicaraguan Exiles
stripped of their citizenship a
prize-winning novelist Sergio Ramirez
and gioconda belly Ramirez has accepted
Colombia's offer of citizenship and
belly that of Chile whom she thanked for
its solidarity of all of Latin America's
left-leaning governments Chile is by far
the harshest critic of Nicaragua's
government and it's also been one of the
first to offer citizenship to those who
mortega has banished and perhaps it's
because hundreds of Chileans suffered
the same fate under this country's
former military dictatorship tonight
who was assassinated by the regime's
agents in Washington DC two weeks after
he was stripped of his citizenship these
people will recover the San Juan Paolo
predicts that like his father albeit
posthumously the nicaraguans will
recover their citizenship and what will
be written in the history books is who
Ortega really is
he is a person who has no respect for
human rights and this doesn't matter if
he's a from the right or from the left
they are dictators
in the meantime more countries are
offering to take in the stateless
dissidents from Nicaragua a country at
Sergio Ramirez describes as a bleeding
wound for Latin America
Lucian human Al Jazeera Santiago